misgendering white privilege and
transphobia to quote alexandria Ocasio
cortez today we run train on the
progressive agenda then what should be
done about steve king we analyze
congressional democrats Apocrypha
finally the left is furious that karen
pens is starting to work at a Christian
school heaven forfend
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
all right before we run train on today's
program we got a run trained on some new
sponsors I want to thank a wonderful new
sponsor spear spear is this a terrific
product I've now just started using it
because I didn't know it existed you
have got to try it too most people hate
writing especially me it took me that 27
years to not write a book though it did
become a best-seller most people hate
writing because word processors are not
designed to help you organize your
thoughts their word processors but
they're not thought processors if you've
ever had writer's block if you ever
stared at that blank screen if you want
to write podcasts or blogs or diary
entries or books or whatever you want to
do spear is a thought processor that
helps you organize your ideas as you
write you can write your thoughts in any
order you want you can move your
thoughts around you can make changes
without the fear of losing your original
idea you will be able to articulate your
ideas faster and easier because it's the
most flexible tool for writing and
thinking most people are not in the know
they just use a word processor this is
so much better the possibilities are
infinite it is like working with Legos
this week my listeners can get spear for
just $3.75 per month for the first year
of service that's a 25% discount off the
regular price sign up today by going to
spear SPE ar e you know like the writer
Shakespeare spear comm slash animals K
no W l es that is spear with an E like
Shakespeare speaking of people who are
not great with their words speaking of
people who could probably use a thought
processor herself Alexandria o Cassio
Cortez AR gaffe prone congresswoman from
upstate New York she's really done it
again this was probably the funniest one
she's done yet she was doing an
interview with a newspaper and she said
quote I'm six days into the term and you
already used all your ammo she's
referring to the right wing
so enjoy being exhausted for the next
two years while we run trained on the
progressive agenda so for those of you
who don't know what running trained
means running train is when a
and a man and a man and a man and
another man and like 10 or 20 other men
and a woman don't love each other very
much but they all get together and they
do that thing that men and women do when
they do love each other that is running
train it's a very graphic sexual act and
Alexandria Cassio Cortez apparently
thought Oh running train means succeed
in implementing I don't know is that
what she thought it meant you can check
out urban dictionary if you don't
believe me although I do warn you about
putting that phrase into your Google
searches you will get some results that
probably you don't want to see this is
just a lovely gap it doesn't have much
to do with her policy proposals it's not
a major news story the reason though
that I really like this one is it this
is what happens when a nice girl from
the suburbs all of a sudden at the age
of 28 decides to pretend that she's
Jenny from the block this is what
happens is you have this girl who grew
up in this lovely little place where the
the dough's are jumping and the little
rabbits or they're you know and it's so
so lovely you go to the community
festivals whatever and she's pretending
now that she's from the Bronx that she's
from the South Bronx the mean streets of
the borough's and she's not and so she's
trying to use slang terms you know
vulgar expressions as though she grew up
in those areas and she didn't and she
doesn't know what they mean and it's
really funny this this is an
authenticity authenticity issue for her
she has a lot of things going for her in
the media she's likable she's bubbly
she's relatively attractive she is young
so she's got all those things going
forward this authenticity thing though
is an issue because pretty soon you're
gonna see her like Miss quoting biggie
smalls or something it doesn't she has
all of the trappings of of people who
are from really privileged areas she's a
socialist she's kind of ditzy she has a
very expensive education even though it
didn't teach her very much and she she's
pretending to use urban language or
vulgar language in a way that doesn't
quite work
Donald Trump you know knock him if you
will the guy really did grow up in
Queens and he really talks like he grew
up in Queens and I bet he knows what
that phrase means moving on to a more
important story but equally for holistic
a CNN analyst Arriva Martin went on a
radio show with conservative radio host
David Webb whereupon she accused David
Webb of white privilege there's only one
problem David Webb is a black guy here's
the exchange I never considered my color
the issue I considered my qualifications
the issue well David you know that
that's a whole nother long conversation
about white privilege the things that
you have the privilege of doing that
people of color don't have the privilege
of how do I have the privilege of white
privilege David by virtue of being a
white male you have white privilege
whole long conversation I don't have
time Arriva
I hate to break it to you but you should
have been better prepped I'm black okay
then I you went to white privilege this
is the fall suit in this new your age he
started to say Arriva I hate to break it
to you I'm black then there's that
moment of silence she says well okay I
can either apologize for just being a
race hustling ignorant cynical
politician or I stand by my men he
starts to cut her off there this is
obviously hilarious one of the best
media moments of the year in a year full
of them already but this is the problem
with the left right now is I identify
this in left-wing rhetoric when you're
debating a leftist when they go on
television when they're in the halls of
Congress or wherever they use so many
logical fallacies and specifically they
use these ad hominem fallacy 'z they
can't argue with the points that you're
making so they just start attacking the
person who's making them and I've just
identified a few of these you've got to
look out for it because whenever the
left throws one of these at you you know
that you've won the argument the first
one you saw it right here is privilege
privilege I mean the way this woman did
it from CNN she went in she felt I don't
need to look up who this guy is I don't
need
look up what this guy thinks all I'm
gonna do I'm assuming he's a
conservative I'm gonna assume he's a
white guy and I'm gonna assume that he
has all of this privilege and she didn't
take a second to even second-guess this
notion and then he tells her I'm a black
guy I you you've done no homework you
know nothing about me
but imagine if that host were a white
guy what could he have said it would
have convinced half the country at least
if he had been a white guy and she'd say
ah but you have white privilege and even
though she can't explain how that
manifests it still would be convincing
this privileged thing is obviously an ad
hominem attack and it means that
arguments are not as important as the
arguer that you should judge a person's
argument based on the color of his skin
or who he is or or where he is rather
than the quality and content of his
arguments the thing that's funny about
privilege though is that no privilege
disqualifies anyone from conversation
what privilege would disqualify anyone
from debate in fact privilege should
over qualify you for debate shouldn't it
if I I've had the privilege of maybe a
few extra brain cells than the average
Joe on the street maybe if I'm lucky
I've had the privilege of a good
education from kindergarten all the way
through college
those are privileges which have actually
prepared me better to think about
certain things and to discuss certain
ideas that's a privilege of education
that's a good thing that's not a
disqualification from debate the left as
we talked about a lot gets reality
backwards so what is a privilege a
privilege is a special advantage for one
person or one group that's a privilege
it's an advantage what the left has
turned privilege into is a disadvantage
they're saying that if you are
privileged you are now too disadvantaged
you can't give your opinion your opinion
is invalid your your political work is
invalid and your vision is invalid it's
it's it Perez the left always does
it's perverting the thing into the
opposite of the thing the advantage into
the disadvantage and by the way
everybody has different privileges
I'm not suggesting that nobody has
privilege I'm not suggesting that
everybody has privilege if that were
true there would be no such thing as
privilege but some people have different
privileges some people are more
athletically gifted
not an Adonis of a man they have more of
a natural privilege in that regard than
I do some people are more mathematically
gifted they have us a privilege in that
way some people are financially gifted
they're born into money I met a lot of
people in my life who were born into
money I was not but many people are
that's a privilege that's an advantage
I'm not going to demonize that I'm not
going to vilify that if you're born into
money
good for you I'm hope that helps your
life and you get a good education and
you have you can enjoy all the pleasures
in the world some people have other
privileges there is a privilege to not
being born into money and the privilege
of that is you learn a little bit how
the world really works you you can see
more how most people are living you can
go through a little bit of suffering
maybe that suffering helps to form your
character makes you stronger makes you
more courageous maybe it makes you more
daring or more ambitious I've seen
plenty of people born into wealth who
become wastrels and I've seen plenty of
people who had nothing growing up really
make something of themselves succeed at
the highest level privilege is really
hard to quantify in some hierarchy of
victimhood which is exactly what the
left wants to do we all to varying
degrees can have a privilege of a reason
some people are unreasonable and some
people have a very low privilege of
reason but but if one has the privilege
of reason then you shouldn't say you
have privilege so you're not allowed to
speak you should say you have that
wonderful privilege of reason please use
it please enlighten me and and describe
the world as you see it the next one
which is very closely related is man
splaining this is also obviously an ad
hominem attack this is also an attack
that says that the arguer is more
important than the argument what what
mansplaining does the funniest thing
about that stupid word is it's like man
spreading man spreading is when men sit
but instead if they're sitting these are
their two legs instead of sitting with
their legs crossed over one another
really tight they're sitting so that
their legs are a little bit apart the
reason they do this in case you didn't
take high school biology class is that
they're making way for certain
anatomical privileges that only men have
and
and do not have so there's a reason for
this it's a commonplace occurrence half
of the population does it the same thing
with mansplaining mansplaining is when a
man explains something now we all
explain things to each other the reason
we do it is because we're human beings
with the faculties of speech so we use
speech and speech is politics speech is
civilization we speak to one another we
don't grunt like the brutes most of the
time so we just talked and we persuade
each other and we try to get each other
to come around to our points of view and
we learn and we instruct and we're
curious and we ask questions so that's
just men explaining what the term
mansplaining does is it portrays as
bizarre or strange when half of the
population does the most basic human
thing that's supposed to be really weird
and strange so you're talking to a girl
who's not girl understanding to use
Andrew clavin's term and she says your
mansplaining you say damn right a
mansplaining now what else can I do I
can't womans plain I don't identify as a
woman I'm sorry about that the way that
they use this of course on the left is
that it's a way of shutting up half of
the population all it means these
phrases check your priveledge these
phrases mansplaining it just means shut
up and the reason that they go after men
is men are more likely to be
conservative obviously there are a lot
of conservative women there are a lot of
very sad left-wing men but generally men
trend more conservative certain
certainly in America so they use it to
shut up half the population the other
one they use is that the phrases safety
and comfort and safe space and that sort
of thing this is a little bit different
but it's playing on the same idea it
still means shut up it's still a logical
fallacy or a discursive fallacy but what
it does is when they say your ideas are
making me feel unsafe the things you're
saying or making me feel threatened
they're making me I'm not in a place of
comfort anymore I hear this all the time
when I go around to colleges we speak at
these colleges will get protested
they'll I have there have been student
groups that have tried to shut us down
with the administration and they'll say
the things that Michael is saying are
unsafe they
they threaten us but of course what are
they threatened what am I talking I'm
talking about
Edmund Burke and that threatens them or
something of course not what they do is
they conflate speech with violence and
so when the left if you're having a
conversation when they accuse you of
this of threatening them of making them
feel unsafe of making them not feel
comfortable what they are essentially
doing is accusing your speaking as
physically assaulting and battering them
they're saying your words are punches
your words are hurting me it says when
you when you couple that with
mansplaining it's that if you're
speaking to a woman and you're
disagreeing with her
you're the equivalent of a wife beater
because you're threatening her you're
making her unsafe you're making her
uncomfortable that's that's the third
one and then just one other this is a
broader observation in the culture of it
it's being led by the left it's being
weaponized by the left is mental illness
mental illness is all the rage these
days it's all anybody can talk about
it's used as an excuse to excuse
terrible behavior and it comes from a
real place young people are much more
likely today to be anxious to be
stressed to be depressed an asu study
found that a quarter of college students
are suffering PTSD because Donald Trump
won the presidential election in 2016
their rates of suicide are increasing
and especially among young people teen
suicide is up 70 percent now and rates
of being prescribed these depression
drugs all of these SSRIs and those sorts
of things are way out there also through
the roof so everybody thinks they have a
mental problem everybody is on
depression drugs constantly talking
about mental illness what it's really
about is not the people the few people
who really could benefit from taking
drugs all the time not the few people
who have worked through their
psychological problems and actually have
a physical problem that requires
medication what this is about is
relativism this is what it's all about
you see it all the time on everyday
feminism on all the really far left wing
websites and podcasts they all say that
they have mental illness and we need to
talk about mental illness and we do need
to describe mental illness and the
reason that they talk about mental
illness all the time is because it
it brings to the fore different visions
of reality but not different visions of
reality using right reasons specifically
different insane visions of reality to
say well this person views things this
way and their their mind is inaccessible
to you because when people are sane when
they have mental health we can use our
faculties of reason to communicate with
one another and we're speaking about an
objective outside world but if everybody
is a little crazy if everybody's a
little kooky nobody's really accessing
the objective world in the right way
then we don't have access to objectivity
anymore we don't have access to reality
anymore we're back in the tyranny of
subjectivism we're back in the tyranny
of our feelings we can't talk about
facts as we said here on The Daily wire
a lot we have to talk about feelings and
nobody can be wrong and nobody can be
right every opinion is valid everything
is your truth or my truth or this truth
or that truth this is why the left is
focused on that this is why not
necessarily on CNN or the Washington
Post but when you go to the really more
fringy more radical left-wing websites
blogs podcasts that's what they're
focusing on it is not out of compassion
for people who have psychological
problems very often by the way people
who have psychological problems have
philosophical problems the issue isn't
the synapses in their brain the issue is
how they're living their lives and how
they view the world and how they view
themselves in relation not only to their
Creator but the rest of the creation and
so they talk about that not out of
compassion for those people but they do
it as a way of advancing their base
agenda which they've had now for at
least 50 or 60 years which is radical
subjectivism speaking of mental illness
and speaking of radical subjectivism
this video first cropped up on the
internet i guess really between
Christmas and New Year's but because
everybody was shut down in the comment
area we haven't gotten a chance to talk
about it we have to talk about it this
is a transgender guy so a guy who
dresses as a woman goes into some store
and starts losing his mind be caught
losing what's left of his mind because
he thinks that somebody has
referred to him a six-foot to giant man
as a man take a look excuse me it's
ma'am it is ma'am you need to settle
down mind your business
okay ma'am once again man no you said
sir right before he said sir sir mother
take it outside call me Ricky I will
show you sir I need your corporate
number because I'm going to talk pile
them atop a house misgendered several
times in the store
I need your corporate number now get for
me now well I'm gonna ask you for the
fifth time to stop calling me a man
because clearly I'm not yes the giant
person screaming shouting six foot tall
knocking over products screaming that
he's gonna go take the kid outside and
beat him up that person is clearly not a
man
giant Adam's apple I assume down below
well I don't know maybe let's not assume
that guy is a man obviously he has a
psychological condition one imagines he
also has a philosophical condition which
is being indulged and encouraged by our
mentally insane society which is that he
thinks that a man can be a woman and a
woman can be a man just because he puts
on lipstick if you put on lipstick then
you're a woman but of course that's not
what makes a woman growing your hair a
little longer is not what makes a woman
I know plenty of scraggly haired hippies
out in LA who have long hair and don't
think that they're women
this thing that we've just watched here
the kid I guess he said okay guys calm
down I think he was using guys in a
gender neutral way and this guy who
thinks he's a woman loses his mind
starts screaming and this kid backs down
and says I'm sorry ma'am I'm sorry lay
it's okay you know and the reason I
bring this up is what this guy's
obviously lost his mind and what's
unfortunate for him is that the society
is even crazier than he is so they're
going to encourage him and let him
continue down this path of
self-deprecation
but the reason I bring this up too is
because it shows where the rubber meets
the road between various schools of
conservative thought if you look at this
guy this guy is a man who wants to be a
woman and if you find your political
views or rooted really in individualism
self definition I can do whatever I want
to do absolutely at any time I own my
life I can define myself however I want
to define myself then he actually makes
a pretty good case for always making
other people call him ma'am or call him
a woman the line from individualism to
collectivism is actually pretty direct I
think sometimes among conservative
circles we want to pretend that the big
dichotomy in the world is between
conservator rather is between
individualism and collectivism one
prioritizes the individual is the
absolute most important thing in society
the other prioritizes the collective all
of those individuals together there are
two sides of the same coin there's a
direct line between them if you say that
the individual is the most important
atomic fundamental building block of
society that in a state of nature
individuals are just floating around in
free space without any ties of loyalty
to family or friends or tribe or country
or whatever if you believe that then
then the government's job is first and
foremost to protect individualism that's
the purpose of goods to protect
individual liberty to the to the point
of individualism but if the government
is there to protect individualism and
our corporate society decides that
they're not going to recognize
somebody's own self definition then that
corporation is infringing on
individualism if this guy says I am a
woman and corporate America or the
government state government or whatever
says that he's not a woman they're not
going to call him a woman they're
infringing on his radical
self-definition and so it makes perfect
sense for there to be regulations over
how businesses can treat people have
schools have to refer to people how to
use pronouns and they use the phrase
misgendered obviously the only person
who has misgendered this guy is himself
he is misgendering himself because he
thinks that he's a woman but they've
inverted this phrase and it does make
sense there is a reason why in the
thinking of all of those early what we
would call classical liberals or even
libertarians if you look at thomas paine
for instance the guy who wrote common
sense force in the american revolution
or the writings of Thomas Jefferson or
people who come after that throughout
the Enlightenment and onward you can see
a line from exalting the individual as
the be-all and end-all at atomic unit of
society and protecting the collective of
individuals the actual difference here
the actual different worldviews is
between liberalism or modernism or
individualism or collectivism or
everything that goes on with it and the
conservative worldview which says there
is a reality you cannot self define you
cannot by yourself define reality there
is an objective reality you are a man no
law passed by any government will change
the fact that that guy's a man no
surgery that is cosmetic and makes an
alters his cheekbones or his Adam's
apple will make that guy not a man no
corporate code of conduct will make that
guy not a man no market no free market
which is now getting all of these
corporations to start playing into the
social justice warrior handbook we saw
this with Gillette we've seen this with
Nike we've seen corporate America
leading the way on liberalism and
leftism no free market is going to
change the fact that this guy is a guy
and it's where we have to appeal to
something deeper more profound more
transcendent rather than the individual
or the free market or certain documents
the constitution or state constitutions
or laws or whatever we have to appeal to
something which is transcendent which is
the natural law and the natural law
the lateral log Giver and the
institutions and the traditions that
have transported these metaphysical
realities into our modern age that is
what we've got to talk about the
question is not about rights it's not
about the rights of the guy who thinks
he's a woman it's not about the rights
of the guy working at the store it's not
about the rights of a Democratic
Republic to pass laws changing the
definition of men and women it's about
reality and we have to recognize reality
we have to prioritize reality above any
of the various ideologies left-wing or
right-wing that everybody is so crazy
about today we've got to talk about
Steve King we haven't had that we've run
out of time the last few days we got to
talk about him we've got to talk about
those cackling hens on the view to quote
Norm Macdonald who we've got to talk
about different kinds of bigotry not
just racial bigotry but also religious
bigotry and if we have time we'll talk
about why we can't run our own countries
after the British Parliament runs train
on Theresa Mays brexit deal but first go
to Daley wire.com
if you're already there thank you very
much you help keep the lights on you
keep khofifah in my cup if you're not
it's ten bucks a month $100 for an
annual membership but Michael what do I
get
what do you get what don't you get you
get me you get the Andrew Clavin show
ben shapiro show matt walsh oh you can't
ask questions backstage get to ask
questions in the mailbag get them in
that'll be tomorrow you get to ask
questions you have to watch all the
backstage that are coming up now you get
to see another Kingdom we've got two
seasons up there now and none of that
matters because you get this you get the
leftist tears tumblr this is very
important because you know now when we
when you take airplanes when you get on
modes of transportation you're not
always allowed to take water bottles or
certain little bottles of perfume or
whatever but when you are running train
on the progressive agenda you are
allowed the FDA the FAA the F T the FA T
the FTA I don't know they allow you to
bring on the leftist years tumblr that's
the only way to do it because when
you're running train on the progressive
agenda there gonna be a lot of leftist
tears as Alexandria cassio Cortes was
describing today you're gonna want this
it is the only safe way to dispose of
those leftist tears to hold them and
then obviously dispose of them down your
gullet go to daily wire comm we'll be
right back with
Steve King
Steve King we've all talked about it but
we haven't had time to address it fully
on this show which is Steve King
longtime congressman he made these
comments allegedly though he hasn't
really denied them in an interview with
the New York Times where he said white
nationalism white supremacy Western
civilization when did these things
become offensive now obviously that that
is offensive to great many people and
just as a simple matter of fact just as
a simple matter of language being
offensive white supremacy has always
been offensive to a very large number of
people some people didn't find it
offensive in the past now more people
find it offensive but it has always been
offensive to some people I think we can
safely say white supremacy has always
carried offense to some people now he
has apologized for this there were calls
for him to step down from Congress he
looks like he's certainly going to be
primary he looks very politically weak
he'll probably be beaten next election
but there were calls to do this to do
that he came out and apologized
immediately and he condemned white
supremacy as an evil ideology here's
that reject those labels and the evil
ideology that they define under any fair
political definition I am simply an
American nationalist okay
the evil ideology he he rejects them he
disavows them okay good I'm glad he did
that I think he felt that was the right
thing to do a lot of his colleagues felt
that was the right thing to do then the
Congress went out and they voted to
condemn or rebuke Steve King it's a
little unclear what the effect of this
is as a matter of terminology was it a
rebuke was it a condemnation was it a
reprimand well okay what the effect of
it though is he's already been stripped
of his committee assignments he won't
sit on any committees he's basically
powerless in the Congress now a pretty
harsh action was taken against him and
I'll point out harsh action was taken
against him for speaking to a reporter
things he said nobody's defending the
things he said I haven't seen one
conservative defend the things that he
said but it is a little scary as far as
a precedent goes that when you say
things to a reporter you can lose
everything in your political career not
by the people who elect you but from
other people in the government
nevertheless okay that's fine they took
a vote to condemn King and his remarks
and Steve King actually voted in favor
of that bill here is King on his own
condemnation so I want to compliment the
gentleman from South Carolina for
bringing this resolution and I've
carefully studied every word in this
resolution and even though I'd add some
more that are stronger language I agree
with the language in it so I want to ask
my colleagues on both sides of the aisle
let's vote for this resolution I'm
putting up a YES on the board here
because what you stay here is right and
it's true and it's just and so is what I
have stated here on the floor of the
House of Representatives thank you madam
Speaker and I yield back the balance of
my time
okay so he's stripped of his committee
seats which means he's doing nothing in
Congress essentially he is condemned by
the Congress he voted for his own
condemnation
he's called those remarks which he says
were misinterpreted
he's called them an evil ideology which
he he disavows what more do they want
from him is the question here is his
defense of the remarks that he made or
rather not he's not defending them but
he is excusing them because he says that
they were misinterpreted so I'm gonna
tell you that the words are likely what
I said but I want to read it to you the
way I believe I said it and that's this
white nationalist white supremacist
Western civilization how did that
language become offensive why did I sit
in classes teaching me about the merits
of our history and civilization that's
the end of the quote just to watch
Western civilization become a derogatory
term in political discourse today
okay so do you buy it do you buy that he
would they were separate thoughts he
said white supremacist white
nationalists beat beat beat beat Western
civilization how did that become
offensive because of course the phrase
western civilization is not offensive
the left finds it offensive but there's
nothing wrong Western civilization is
the greatest political achievement in
the history of the world now
do you buy that excuse I don't really
buy it I it's even the way he's
describing it it's a little mealy
mouthed he's I don't know it's a little
too clever by half so let's say that
Steve King said it he conflated Western
civilization with white supremacy he
said remarks that had been universally
condemned across the political aisle by
his own party by his own colleagues he's
been condemned rebuked to reprimanded he
voted for his own condemnation he's off
of all the committee's okay okay that's
all fine I'm with you so far but what
about the Democrats what about what
about what about Michigan first term
representative Rasheeda Talib was
pictured just recently just within the
last couple weeks with a Palestinian
activist named Abbas Hamidah who
regularly praises Hezbollah Hezbollah a
terrorist organization and is called
Jews Zionist terrorists
Rashidah to leave that same person right
when she got into the Congress took a
sticky note to the map of the world in
her office wrote in Palestine and
covered up Israel Israel these the only
state for Jews in the world plenty of
states for Arabs plenty of states for
Muslims one state in the entire world in
all of history for Jews she symbolically
wipes it off the face of the map where
is her condemnation
where is her apology I didn't never saw
her upon Steve King apologized he called
it an evil ideology where's her calling
it an evil ideology Minnesota
representative Alon Omar another
Democrat freshman wrote on Twitter quote
Israel has hypnotized the world may
Allah awaken the people
and help them see the evil doings of
Israel hashtag Gaza hashtag Palestine
hashtag Israel now this Steve King
referred to white supremacy he was
conflated with neo-nazis these types in
his speech condemning that evil ideology
he said it was the evil ideology that
led Hitler to wipe 6 that a 6 million
Jews off of the face of the earth that
anti-jewish ideology is an ideology
being embraced by Ilan Omar and Rasheeda
Talib openly embraced not in and off not
in a unrecorded interview with the New
York Times where we don't have the tape
to listen to it but publicly on Twitter
they defend it still and the Democrats
defend it still where is that apology
where is that vote of condemnation
Barack Obama former president two-term
president hope and change took a smiling
photo with Louis Farrakhan the head of
the Nation of Islam
he's called Jews termites he refers to
every other race as awful and terrible
white Devils a minister truly a minister
of racial bigotry and hatred and there's
Barack Obama smiling with him couldn't
be happier and you know what happened
the mainstream media had that photo
before the 2008 election they hit it
they didn't want it to come out
it has since come out where's Barack
Obama's apology where is Barack Obama
calling that an evil ideology I just see
smiles I don't see him calling an evil
ideology where is the vote to condemn
and rebuke and reprimand Barack Obama
you might say Michael this is what about
ISM what about ISM is when you we're
talking about one topic one person one
act and then you point out hypocrisy by
saying well what about this other person
or this other act that hasn't been
equally condemned and really what about
ISM compares apples to oranges when the
phrase became popular during the Cold
War it was about comparing apples to
oranges I'm comparing apples to apples
here I'm compiling comparing
contemporary politician to contemporary
politician on both sides of the aisle
the only difference of course is that
Steve King has been remorseful and has
apologized and Democrats are still proud
of it all they're still smiling
and they're still championing these
these almost identical ideologies and if
it's what about ISM well what about what
about ISM what about it I would vote
along with Steve King for that rebuke
for that condemnation of Steve King and
his remarks but before I did that I
would insert an amendment if I were in
Congress and I would also include a
rebuke of Rasheeda Talib and Ilan Omar
in Barack Obama for smiling with Louis
Farrakhan I would insist on that being
included in the condemnation and the
rebuke and we should have done that as
well I think Republicans they want to
get rid of Steve King because he's
politically poisonous at this point and
he's passed his political usefulness and
he's been in the career for a long time
and he's probably gonna lose his primary
next go-around they just want to stop
talking about it fine I get the
political expedience of that but I would
insist on including those condom nations
of Omar Talib and Barack Obama because
without those condom nations also in the
condemnation of Steve King it is very
clear that Democrats have no interest
whatsoever in condemning racial bigotry
they're only interested in attacking the
GOP and they're not even just interested
in attacking the GOP they're interested
in using Steve King as a proxy to attack
Donald Trump they don't care about Steve
King Steve King is just some congressman
one of over 400 people just doesn't who
cares whether he's you know he doesn't
affect the country in the way that the
President does and they want to call the
president racist and bigoted and this is
the maddest they want to tie the issue
of illegal immigration to racism somehow
that's all they want to do and they are
unwilling to deal with it in their own
party Linda Sarsour
another anti-semite was given an award
by Barack Obama in the White House as
she has had close ties to the Democratic
Party and to the women's March the list
goes on and on and on if they want to
condemn Steve King by all means go for
if they want to condemn racial bigotry
and hatred please great more power to
you but do it on both sides
otherwise you're a fake you're a fraud
you're a cynical politician that's what
the Democrats are on this issue let's
see what those cackling hens to use
Norma Donald's phrase had to say at the
view about this issue Republicans now
step up to the plate with Donald Trump
because he has been using I think the
border wall as sort of this dog whistle
for racism the government is still shut
down and I think it's all about let's
not let all these brown people in right
unless they're working for farmers
unless they're working in agriculture so
now will the Republican Party's step up
to him and say we don't want it city
there anymore there's 42 percent of this
country that isn't worth the wall are
they all racist that's a good question I
don't think so I didn't know a lot of
people that believed in I don't know you
okay so goes on gotta love Abbey
Huntsman my old pal she just is great
there she says what do you think half
the country is racist and this woman
whose name I don't know says well that's
a good question and whenever someone
says well that's a good question it
means they just have no idea what
they're gonna say they have nothing to
say you always on whether I'm conducting
an interview or I'm on a panel with
somebody and we're doing interviews and
you say what do you think about this
they'll say that's a good question say I
know it's a good question I thought it
up I'm thank you for the compliment
answered a question but she thinks oh
this woman clearly thinks that half of
the country is racist and Republicans
are is Steve King racist is the wall
racist they asked okay are Barack Obama
and Ilan Omar and Rasheeda Talib racist
or they are Democrat analysts on CNN
racist for trying to shut up white
people by using these ad hominem attacks
white privilege ironically against a
black guy doesn't work every time to do
your research next time what about other
kinds of bigotry cuz we're just focusing
on racism but I don't only want to run
trained on racism I want to run trained
on all sorts of bigotry and the biggest
one that's cropping up in the news cycle
is religious bigotry this is far more
prevalent obviously Christians around
the world are the most persecuted
religious group on earth right now and
it's reached record highs certainly in
modern history
the left doesn't get this the left
doesn't get religious bigotry whether
it's Islamic militants abusing
Christians in the Middle East or whether
it's leftists in in a different way in a
more legal way or rather a legislative
way or a regulated way trying to attack
Christians in the United States the left
doesn't get this because the left
doesn't take religion seriously the left
takes race very seriously the left takes
race too seriously they think that
everything is about race so much so that
a CNN analyst will accuse a black
political commentator of having white
privilege that's how obsessed they are
about race they take race too seriously
they don't take religion seriously
enough so Karen pence who is the wife of
vice president Mike Pence she was a
schoolteacher it was just announced
she's going to take a job as a
schoolteacher she's gonna teach at this
Christian school and continue her career
I think she got tired of hanging around
the Naval Observatory and so she's gonna
do this wonderful for her great
opportunity for the students how did NBC
News report it they said quote Karen
pence to teach at school that bans LGBTQ
employees and students what what school
does that I let's look a little more
closely here this school which is a
Christian school in reality this is
quoting from later on in the NBC article
bars its employees from engaging in or
condoning homosexual or lesbian sexual
activity and transgender identity so
it's not banning people who are
attracted to members of the same sex
it's not banning people who identify or
think that they are members of the
opposite sex it's just saying you can't
engage in that sort of activity which
what that really means is that a
Christian school expects its teachers to
agree with Christian sexual teaching
which is not just Christian sexual
teaching but it's Jewish sexual teaching
it's a in in the extremist world it
would be Muslim sexual teaching
Christian sexual teaching is pretty
loosey-goosey compared to other
religions traditional moral teachings on
the basis of a Christian education which
is what these kids are going to this
school for is to teach the Christian
view of the world and a lot of atheist
or secularist or whatever humanist
modernist people now they want to say uh
what do they want to learn that stupid
Christian view of the world what do you
think people were walking around with
dinosaurs uh what I was big dumb idiots
the the Christian view of the world as a
basis for education is the only basis
for education just historically speaking
if you enjoy all of the advancements
over the last twelve or thirteen hundred
years in math or science or literature
or history historiography or philosophy
or anything like that you can thank the
Christian view of the world and the
Christian basis of Education education
as we know it would not exist anywhere
in the world if it were not invented by
the Catholic Church in the mid to late
Middle Ages it would not exist all of
the universities all of the Cathedral
schools all of our all of the
metaphysical basis of education itself
that we have in our modern world it
comes from Christianity and it comes
from specifically the Catholic Church so
she wants to teach at this Christian
school that's fine the Christian school
wants its students and employees to
agree to a Christian morality the left
of course hates Christianity so it's
very upset about this what if it were
announced what if we had a president
whose first lady was Muslim and it was
announced that this woman was going to
teach at a madrasah a Muslim school do
you think that madrasah would celebrate
homosexual activity sexual activity do
you think it would celebrate the
transgender movement transgenderism ah
something tells me it wouldn't and what
would happen then NBC news would be
thrilled they would be saw how brave how
brave and beautiful this first like
she's teaching cuz she loves children
and she loves education and she oh she's
at a Muslim school this is so wonderful
but because it's a Christian school they
hate it and this is why NBC News in the
left they don't care
the LGBTQ LMNOP employees are students
they don't care about that whatsoever
they are using them as they always use
the ever multiplying victim groups as an
instrument as a tool with which to
clobber conservatives and the tradition
that's all it's about I I would love it
if Karen pence went on sabbatical at the
Christian school went to teach at a
madrasah we'd see how the news covered
that probably very differently because
they are they are unlike us they are
unwilling in the progressive agenda to
run train on bigotry and hatred and
racism and all of those other nefarious
ideologies that's our show we got a lot
more to get to but too bad get your
mailbag questions in for tomorrow in the
meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Nolt show I will see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Robert Sterling executive producer
Jeremy Moore senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico
audio is mixed by Dylan case production
assistant Nick shyam hair and makeup is
by Jessa
of era the Michael Noel's show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19